now all you've got to do is call
reunited and it feels so good i don't
even know where to begin
adrian bailone and tamara mowry housley
came together face to face for the first
time
in a year on wednesday adrian shared a
series of photos on vacation in upstate
new york where she had the chance to
reconnect with her old pal
and former co-host of the real posting
this emotional video
you've got a friend tamira also posted a
photo of the two with the caption
writing my forever girl crush
proud of you a it was a year too long
since i've seen your gorgeous face
it was just like we left off you will
forever have my heart
i love love love you always and their
reunion didn't stop there
the two spent the day at the inn at
pound ridge relaxing
enjoying cocktails and taking in the
view their reunion comes after tamira's
decision to leave the real last year to
move to napa with her family
in september adrian told et how she felt
about her leaving the show so
when tamara decides you know that she's
no longer going to be a part of the show
what's that process like
like saying goodbye to her i think
naturally it's bittersweet we're like
man we we love having you but at the
same time when you're genuinely
someone's friend
you know what makes them happy and i
know that being with her children
and being in nappa with her husband and
running their business there and all the
other opportunities
and the dreams that she still wants to
fulfill as a friend we're like
girl yes like you got this we know that
this next journey
the next steps that she's gonna take are
gonna be phenomenal and we're excited to
see those happen
those dreams come true for her so again
we're like
damn we gonna miss you tam that rhymed
but we're also just so proud of her and
so happy for her in real life
and as for tamara she told et last year
how she's settling with her new life in
napa and why the move was best for her
family
you came into our living rooms every day
for seven years but
now you're full time living in napa
working on your your vineyard and this
amazing family that you've created what
does life look like for you
now in this next chapter there's one
word i can
think of and it's peace
i have peace i have peace because i'm
with my family
and my family rejuvenates me being
around
i am so grateful and i am so blessed
that i am able to say those words i
realize that
it doesn't mean we don't have stressful
days it doesn't mean that there aren't
days where
i just want to like you know scream
right
it's it's that's normal but i love my
family
and you know people have seen me talk
about that for seven years
it's true so being around my family
being there for my children they're at
an age right now where they want
mommy around you know i like i'm a
hands-on
parent i know i like you know to to
help them whether it's in you know
soccer dance
obviously it's pretty coveted um but we
still do those things
at home with school with with homework
and we started you know my husband has
had the winery for years with his family
but we
are now in control over it it's pretty
awesome when your father-in-law is like
here you want this and you're like what
but tamira also made it clear she's not
done with her tv career just yet
what does the next five to ten years
look like for you is it acting is it
posting is it wine is it being a
full-time mom and
maybe putting the other stuff on the
back burner you you actually
said everything that i want to do in the
next five
ten years i loved doing my talk show
i i you know it was great it was it
i did it for seven years i built an
amazing family
i learned a lot about myself about
people the importance
of your voice and not being afraid to
you know
vocalize your opinion because you never
know who is out there that truly needs
to hear your words
and you know who knows in the future i
just i just know right now i'm
focusing on my family and
and acting
you